whether you're an evening type morning
type or somewhere in between and it's
about a third third split across the
population it is not your fault it is
genetically determined largely and there
are at least 22 different genes that we
now know will dictate your chronotype
destiny it's gifted to you at Birth you
can't really change it very much
unfortunately so how does chronotype fit
into your innate Cadian Rhythm
chronotype dictates were that sort of
wave where that oscillation of rising
activity and then the lull of sleep
where that sits on the 24-hour clock
face so we all have a sadrian rhythm but
if you are a morning type your Peak
activity will arrive earlier on the
clock face whereas if I'm a neutral
which I am I I'm just going to sit
somewhere in the middle and then the you
know the party people uh their peak of
activity won't start happening or Rising
until the afternoon